Julius Pope Julius, the first, no relation to orange Julius,
the drink shop chose December 25th to be Christmas.
It is commonly believed that the church chose this date in an effort to adopt
and absorb the tradition of the pagan center. Nali, a festival, Santa Alia.
It sounds like something Sergio should coma dance. Yeah, here's the thing.
I mean, what are the chances now? I believe in God. I really do. Now.
You believe in God, you have the baby almost died. Now you believe in God.
I've had mold life and death experiences.
I took an old clown up in a old sausage out of fridge.
I had my heart rate go down to 20. I, you know,
they had to give me an adrenaline. Would you?
If there's no in between either your heart rate's too low or too high. Yeah. I,
when you can't figure it out, I got shot with a gun.
I've been electrocuted by lightning. Oh, you can take an electric bike,
like struck by lightning. I've been shot with a gun. Now I got COVID.
I was never really in danger of dying from COVID. But if they,
if I didn't go to the hospital, my sodium levels that could have got weird.
You could have got weird, but it couldn't go up, but it didn't happen,
but they are kind of brushes with death. And um, yeah. I mean, I'm not,
I don't know if this is true, but there's definitely something bigger. Sure.
And, and it may be an too. I mean,
if you look at the way animals eat each other and the way things are and that
there's fumes in the world, he may be an. Could be,
God could be an because why make fumes? Humes are unnecessary.
Can't be God and hygienists. It's one of the things, one of the other,
but my question to you is Jesus Christ.
What are the chances he just was not mentally ill. Yeah.
Cause, cause I think I thought I was Jesus for about a week college. Jesus,
there is a many people and I ride the line. Yeah.
You ride the line because the dead sea scrolls, which, you know,
became popular when they got found, I don't know, 30, 40 years ago. Um,
they kind of say that the Jesus Christ Jesus, who, who the Bible goes,
who council of Nicea has picked as the Jesus that we know that guy who's painted
on my back was tattooed on my back. That guy,
that guy, you and Bobby DeNiro and Cape fear. Yeah. So that guy,
he was one of,
there were upwards of 12 to 15 people in that hundred year time saying they were
the Messiah. So council of Nicea just picked one. Just picked once.
No doubt about it. There was a man named Jesus doing what he was doing.
Jesus. I love the way you were pronounced it. Jesus, Jesus.
You hear the way he's saying it. Jesus, Jesus, us Jesus. Because, but,
but there was not a Puerto Rican [inaudible] there was a many people. Yeah.
Because make no mistake, make no mistake.
I just got a house on Staten Island and there's going to be a lot of weddings in
my back yard. Oh yeah. It's got a nice low interest rate.
Shout out the scumbag mortgage
[inaudible] does not Chrissy. Now you've already got legal things,
but to nobody I'm saying they're good.
I'm saying the 2.5 minutes called him a scumbag. No, no, but I mean,
I don't mean scrub. I mean, I shouldn't have said scumbag. I meant sleazy.
I mean, whatever, you come out with a 2.5 interest rate. Something's illegal,
but I'm listening. Yeah.
And I'm it in for the low rate because it got the ten-year-old old mortgage.
If I could put your, if I could make an analogy for your mouth,
it would be the wild West. Yes. You're jelly the kid you're yeah.
You're you're you're your mouth. Is this bang. Bang, bang, bang, bang, bang.
What is Yosemite? Sam? It's almost like you got three mouths. Yeah.
Like Neil Brendan's three mikes. It's three mikes. I got over here.
You got trouble over here. And you got drama over here. Three bikes.
I got three miles. You should do a special where? Here you go. Okay.
Now I'm going to lie.
Now I'm going to tell the truth. Okay. Now here,
I'm going to tell you about my anxiety. That's true. I'm twitching.
I'm twitching night. Terrors night terrors. Yeah, no,
we're going to go over here where I'm, it's a spin the wheel baby.
I'm back together. Well baby's mama. Yeah, back there. My baby mama.
More mouths to feed. What can you do?
I got duped into buying a house on Staten Island. It's Christy three mikes.
You mean, is there a chance he wasn't mentally ill. I mean, I could,
I thought I was Jesus Christ for a little while with Jesus Christ.
That's an issue. Did you really genuinely think that your finger get that high?
That you started to hallucinate for real? No. When I was in college though,
I went to, I think I had a little moment where I had like a little megalomania.
Right. And I thought like, Oh my Jesus, you know, stresses,
things like that, you know? Yeah. Also do you think he could be an alien?
Could Jesus be an alien? Why the hell? Not because I mean, the,
the Israeli said that the aliens are real and they have a contract with them.
Maybe the contract started around now. It's very possible because yeah.
One guy always comes out and says that. I mean,
there's no aliens here. I mean, if they will, no, we're in a contract with them.
That's what the Israeli defense contract. They sat down with their lawyers. Yes.
With their alien lawyers. That's what they say.
Because people say all types of things. That's the problem with the internet.
That's why I got blocked by Dave Rubin because at one point, uh, you know, uh,
one point in, uh, November, he goes, if,
can we at least admit that the pandemic's over? And I just lost it.
My brother and we cried. We cried. We cried.
It's been a lot of atoning going on. It's what it is. Cut to Yani. Atonement.
Cause I'm on Molly right now. Yeah. That's what it is. I'm on Molly.
Nature's Molly, right? Yeah. Yani is on drugs right now. I will.
I want to touch all you guys. Yeah. Do you want some CBD gummies?
We got five CBD. Shut up. Five CBD. Everything's alive. Everything's alive.
These cameras are alive or we'll touch them. I'll get an erection.
These cameras. Yeah. Cause remember we're cosmic pinball machines.
I got therapy in one minute. Yeah.
You got therapy woman because Joanne positive is finishing later.
Cause we're having so much fun.
Do or do you got babies to pick up and are there Jews on the windows?
There's Jews on the windows? Yeah. I met. I'll see how long I can stay.
I got it. Even though I put it an offer on a house,
I'm taking a look at another house on Staten Island.
I actually got five minutes. What are you doing for Christmas?
I'm salute and Kamala Harris aides. That's what I'm doing too. Yeah.
I mean, I can't see my mud on Christmas. I'm not why not? Well, no,
because I don't think we're doing small indoors. I think we're going to do.
And we're going to do Thanksgiving and I don't actually know.
I think I am doing, we are going to do Christmas. Cause I mean, yeah,
the truth is Ridgewood is just, doesn't give a about the virus.
And the thing is, it seems like you just can't get it. I don't know. I'm still,
I'm still really I'm proceeding with caution, but I know, I do not know.
I mean it, there was a few times where it was like, how didn't you get it? Yeah.
I don't know. It's almost like pimp doesn't get it either. No,
but pimp is always strapped. Yeah. I mean she me strapped him strapped. Yeah.
Like I said, pimp walks around looking like he's about to paint the ceiling.
Yeah. Yeah. You, you, you RA daddy. I don't know. Yeah.
I don't know where we were on election.
That you were screaming at them for them to take their masks off.
And you invited another person in here. So my wife has got,
what is Chrissy doing? And I'm going,
the kid doesn't feel unless there's danger in the air. It's what it is.
[Inaudible].